رساله تحذير امريكيه جديده توجهها واشنطن
هذه المره عبر مجلس
الامن القرار يركز فقط على هجمات الحوثيين
في جنوب البحر الاحمر ويدين هذه الهجمات
ويدعو الى وقفها فورا ويشير القرار في اهم
بنوده الى حق الدول في الدفاع عن سفنها ضد
الهجمات التي تقوض حريه الملاحه في البحر
الاحمر وفقا للقانون الدولي
يطالب القرار الحوثيين بشكل لا لبس فيه
بوقف هجماتهم المتهوره التي تنتهك القانون
الدولي ويؤكد دعم المجلس للحقوق والحريات
الملاحيه للسفن التابعه لجميع الدول في
البحر الاحمر تشكل هجمات الحوثييين
المتكرره على الشحن الدولي تهديدا امنيا
وتهديدا اقتصاديا حيث تزيد الاسعار التي
يدفعها الناس مقابل الغذاء والوا والطاقه
ويؤكد القرار على انها تشكل ايضا تهديدا
للمساعدات
الانسانيه القرار اعتمد بالاغلبيه وتحفظت
عليه روسيا والصين والجزائر وموزمبيق وهو
يتجاهل تماما الحرب الدمويه في غزه
ويتعامل مع التوتر في البحر الاحمر كاز
منفصله وضع حاولت روسيا تغييره عبر اقتراح
تعديلات قالت انها تمنع تاسيس القرار
لكنها
اخفقت لقد امتنعنا عن التصويت على مشروع
القرار الذي اعدته الولايات المتحده
واليابان بشان الملاحه الامنه في البحر
الاحمر ونؤكد مره اخرى انه لا يمكن اعتبار
هذا القرار شرعنه للاعمال التي يقوم بها
ما يسمى بالتحالف المكون من الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في البحر الاحمر كما ان
القرار لا يمكن ان يختلق حقا غير موجود
للدول في الدفاع عن سفنها من الهجمات وفق
هذه المرجعيه ويجب ان يتم ذلك بما يتماشى
بشكل صارم مع القانون الدولي
الحالي القرار يعكس مع ذلك موقفا مشتركا
يسعى الى تجنب التصعيد في البحر الاحمر
والمنطقه عموما ويدعو الى ضبط النفس
وتعزيز الجهود الدبلوماسيه في هذا الشان
واللافت هو تحرك واشنطن السريع في مجلس
الامن في هذا الشان في وقت لا تزال تمثل
فيه العائق الاكبر امام تحرك مجلس الامن
لوقف الحرب في
غزه